I have lived off my insecurities as a
comedian and I look at your comedy
there's never been a hint of insecurity
is that fair yeah it is I've never shown
it but I'm a brilliant and skilled
performer and actor it's true
the audience terrifies us yeah come
scare the [ __ ] out of the audience you
know I used to do that Richard Pryor he
was gonna be blackboard yeah
but they wouldn't have it we saw a lot
of guys auditioning for blackboard I
said Richard I love this guy
it was Cleavon little yeah and Richard
said you know if I wrote in to town was
my kind of tan face of my black mustache
I look more like a Cuban he said but
this guy he is black he will scare the
[ __ ] out of them this is a true story
but can't believe it he orders a shrimp
cocktail sirloin steak asparagus and a
baked potato he eats that Jesus George
I still feel a bit peckish do the game
I always walk upstage depressed yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
when can people see this on their on
their computers uh week of the 21st 21st
of what which month thank you this I'm
impatient with him yeah yeah October 21
smiles over 21